heavy security for the kazakh president
in almaty to meet with the families of
18 servicemen killed in last week's
violent unrest
but what about the protesters killed we
still don't know how many
there are terrible images from inside
the city morgue circulating on social
media showing corridors lined with body
bags bullets to the head in video that
we won't show you
undertaker's vans outside to take away
the bodies of friends and loved ones it
is no way to say goodbye
my friend didn't participate in this
action he was in his friend and to go to
home and near the home he
grabbed by
army
and they killed him
sagi akhtanov lost his cousin who was in
almaty on a business trip his sister has
come from their hometown to identify the
body
the outburst of violence and the
authority's lethal crackdown was swift
and extremely brutal
asghar zalimoth is a political activist
and was in the main square as the
protests turned violent
i think
[Music]
the russian-led peacekeeping mission
starts its withdrawal this thursday and
should be out of the country in a little
over a week but things are far from
bringing back to normal
in pact detention centers that we can't
access there are ten thousand people
detained some of whom were badly injured
in last week's protests who aren't
getting the medical care that they need
or any access to lawyers
the cleanup continues
kazakhstan entering a new era where
long-time leader no sultan nazarbayev is
no longer even nominally in charge but
what a price to pay to get rid of the
old man
dynamic sky news almaty kazakhstan